the other guy that announced obviously
was former vice president Mike Pence he
then did a CNN Town Hall I thought this
was the most interesting snippet from it
sir on that Donald Trump says he quote
incline
many members of the mob who attacked the
capitol on January 6. those people were
of course part of the same mob who built
Gallows and chanted about wanting to
hang you
would you consider partying and
pardoning any of them
you know on the day of January 6 I
issued a tweet
demanding that people leave the Capitol
and end the violence
and I said that those that failed to do
that should be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law
and I continue to believe that today
we cannot ever allow what happened on
January 6 to happen again in the heart
of our democracy and I'll stand by the
decisions and the due process of court
in our laws and I I have no interest or
no intention
partnering those that that assaulted
police officers
vandalized our Capital they need to be
answerable to the law
Liz I think it's worth noting that Trump
didn't pardon any of those people when
he had the chance he also didn't raise
funds for them or anything else he was
president and could have done something
in those last days he did not but
Pence's answer I suspect you're you're
not digging
no I find that answer infuriating first
of all we don't know who erected that
Gallows because we haven't gotten the
full videotape footage of everything
that happened on January 6th so he is
actually casting aspersions on
conservatives when he doesn't know that
that is the case that's the first thing
and by the way we do know we do know
that there's that there were at least 20
feds right we know that there were at
least 20 feds and probably more on the
ground there
oh far more 20 is a small number 20 is
about the number that embedded just with
the proud boys or The Oath Keepers let
alone the entirety of those protests or
in and around the capitol he says he
stands by due process of law vice
president Pence what due process of law
are you talking about are you talking
about the two years of pre-trial
detention in solitary confinement that
many of these defendants suffered
um for what for for going through a
barrier that had been broken down for
not committing any violence not
committing any vandalism not harming
anyone not assaulting a police officer
are you talking about the conviction of
a man who didn't bring a weapon into the
capital who didn't tell anybody to bring
a weapon into the capital who didn't
even enter the capital didn't tell
anybody to enter the capital and because
of the content of his private text
messages saying edgy things that our
government didn't like he is now
convicted to 18 years in prison this is
beyond disqualifying for vice president
Pence Beyond disqualifying there is not
a single Republican or conservative
regardless of what you think of what
happened on Jan January 6 regardless of
whether you think the people should have
been there regardless of whether some
people committed vandalism and some
people should be held accountable under
the law for that there's not a single
Republican that should ever cast a vote
for a man that stands by how the
government has weaponized law
enforcement and our Criminal Justice
System against these American citizens
Liz the thing with you is I can never
tell how you really feel you know you're
always you're always you're always
always hiding it always hiding it let me
say this Dave yeah let me say this let
me say this this is a topic that I get
tremendous Flack for talking about
because people say oh it's a conspiracy
theory or you're siding with people who
said horrible things which some of them
did or did things they shouldn't have
done like vandalize and they shouldn't
have done that but let me tell you the
reason that the left is using January
6th and these prosecutions as political
prosecutions is for that exact reason
for the same reason that Twitter kicked
Alex Jones off first because so many
people don't want to defend what these
people said or did but that doesn't
justify violating people's
constitutional rights to due process of
law and targeting them because they dare
to support Trump and dare to question
the outcome of the 2020 presidential
election